[Musique]
moi
parlant j'entends vos voix
j'entends l'univers sonore mais par là
je n'entends rien
je suis sourde
extrêmement sourde mais pas muette
et puis j'ai fait une découverte - mais
plus
je n'ai qu'une oreille mais j'ai deux
sons de cloche mon cerveau est mon corps
mon cerveau est en discussions
permanentes avec le monde qui nous
entoure
mon corps est en discussions permanentes
avec moins mais je n'entendais pas
c'est pas facile d'écouter son corps non
et pourtant ça change la voix ça change
la voix et ça change la voix
mais je vous ai perdu non alors la voix
vo x on est d'accord elle s'entend et la
voix vo i e elle se cherche c'est une
destination
et pourquoi écouter son corps changerait
la voie et la voix et bien c'est ça ce
que je vais vous raconter ce soir
prenons un peu de hauteur
comme je n'écoutais pas mon corps il a
monté le son
ça m'a déséquilibré je me suis mise à
tomber tout le temps je faisais des
vertiges
je pourrais dire que mon corps m'a
obligé à
l'écouté
pas trouvé sa mystique movie
comme je suis journaliste j'avais très
envie de comprendre je cherchais des
explications et j'ai trouvé alain
beaudet qui est docteur en sciences
physiques
il explique que les sons ont une
résonance pas seulement sur nos tympans
mais sur différentes parties de notre
corps et que selon la hauteur et le
timbre du son que nous entendons
notre corps peut réagir communiqué et
que apprendre à écouter ses résonances
nous permet de développer d'autres
apprentissages
moi j'entends des passes et résonances
tue pas la seule je suis sûr
parce que finalement on n'a pas
tellement envie d'écouter le monde
autour de nos avec nos tripes nous
redoutons les émotions qui sont
désagréables qui font mal
et surtout je crois que nous croyons que
penser avec nos tripes risque souvent
d'être trop bouleversant et cette
surdité elle commence à ces jeunes
le magazine l'étudiant en 2015
comptabilisait qu un tiers des étudiants
regrettent leur choix d'études en 2016
qu'un tiers des étudiants est convaincu
que son décrochage scolaire est dû à une
erreur d'orientation
en 2020 un bachelier sur deux échoué à
la fin de sa première année post bac
selon vous il écoute quoi les étudiants
leurs tripes
la peur de l'avenir
on leur file un peu au passage
entrée dans le monde du travail c'est
l'entrepôt lot david gras verts qui lui
mène une enquête auprès des employés et
évalue à peu près à 45 % le nombre de
personnes qui qualifient leur activité
professionnelle de bullshit job
et que c'est très désagréable à accepter
combien de bullshit life
selon vous combien de personnes autour
de vous et steam vivre une bullshit life
apparemment enviable
et quand vous entendez ce que je vous
raconte
qu'est ce que vous ressentez
bien ses émotions
qu'on veut absolument gérer comme un
compte en banque
elles ont suscité ma curiosité
je voulais pas encore dit mais je suis
aussi scénographe et pendant dix ans
j'ai écrit des parcours où tout se
manipule pour des musées et puis j'ai
fait un super marché des émotions qui
est une exposition sur 800 mètres carrés
pour toute la famille parce que j'ai la
sensation que notre rapport aux émotions
a quelque chose à voir avec notre
rapport aux rayons des magasins
certains d'entre nous ne mettre les
pieds que au rayon bonbons et jamais au
rayon yaourts ou sur violet est bien
certain entre nous ne fréquente que la
colère d'autres ne vont jamais du côté
du chagrin
pas mal ont besoin de renouveler un peu
leur stock de joie régulièrement
dans cette exposition tout et ludique
parce que le jeu med a détourné ce que
je ressens
à faire la sourde oreille
je fais très très bien
tellement bien qu'à ce moment là les
collectivités m'appelle elles veulent
mon exposition supermarchés des émotions
mais elle est trop grande alors je
confectionne une exposition sur mesure
qui tient dans ma voiture et j'installe
des infirmeries à émotions dans des
lieux d'accueil de l'enfance souvent en
grandes difficultés
des centres de loisirs des écoles des
services psychiatriques de l'enfance en
milieu hospitalier
et là j'entends du soulagement
[Musique]
les gosses s'installe à 6 joyeusement
dans cette façon de communiquer avec
leurs émotions
pas d'injonctions
pas d'objectifs à atteindre
pas de gestion
pas d'émotion a nommé juste du jeu du
partage
de la découverte
de la compréhension intuitive
une façon de transformer les émotions en
geste créatif
beaucoup d enfants que j'ai fréquenté
pendant les dix ans d'activité de feu
mon association l'infirmerie à émotions
mon permis d'entendre autrement mais
installations
les autistes et les hyperactifs surtout
parce que chez eux le volume du son est
au maximum en permanence il n'y a plus
de place pour écouter le monde qui est
autour de nous c'est à l'intérieur que
c'est bruyant tout le temps
cette expérience a profondément changé
ma voix de journalistes
finalement c'est moins les histoires
qu'on se raconte qu'ils commandent que
le corps qui cherche son équilibre en
permanence
j'ai changé de fréquence sonore je ne
tombe plus
je crois que j'entends autrement les
autres autour de moi
j'entends ce que je n'écoutais pas
quand je dois interviewé un auteur par
exemple je lis son livre je fais des
recherches et je me suis rendu compte
que je le fais autrement parce que
j'ai mené une expérience après celle de
l'infirmerie à émotions
pour évaluer la façon quotidienne pour
moi de saisir ce que je savais faire
je sais interviewé je sais écouter
je sais détourner la réalité en jeu je
sais transformer les émotions
alors je les fais sur moi sur mon corps
j'ai essayé d'interviewer mon corps de
l'écouté et petit à petit
j'ai scénographié mon corps en
détournant la réalité en imaginant des
espaces d'activités
mon coeur est un grand salon dans lequel
il ya des tas de fauteuils club sur
lesquels il ya mes amis tout le temps
voire trop souvent
mon cerveau au début ressembler à un
bureau rempli de tiroirs avec beaucoup
de papier c'était un univers très sombre
très chargé depuis j'ai fait le ménage
j'ai ouvert les fenêtres et aéré j'ai
rangé
maintenant ça ressemble à un endroit
plus épuré plus aérien plus lumineux
dans lequel je vais facilement quand
j'ai envie de réfléchir
mes jambes ont quelque chose de
l'univers à la tolkien comme ces arbres
qui se déplace beaucoup plus facilement
quand il estime que le déplacement vaut
le coup de se déplacer
mon ventre ci a progressé aujourd'hui ça
ressemble un peu à une oasis
au début ça ressemblait à un terrain
vague
cette expérience là
elle m'a permis de prendre des notes
quand je prépare une interview tout à
fait différemment
je continue de lire les livres d'un
auteur si je dois l'interviewer je
continue de faire des recherches mais je
me suis rendu compte que c'est avec mon
corps que je le fais sans le vouloir
je réagis à ce que je ressens
dans un livre sur un détail une phrase
une façon de dire un style
ça a changé mes interviews parce que
quand je suis en face de l'auteur j'ai
mes notes avec moi mais je me suis rendu
compte que je les regarde plus du tout
parce qu'en fait mon corps se souvient
parfaitement de ce que j'ai ressenti je
ne mène plus une interview je suis en
conversation avec un auteur parce que je
suis pleinement avec lui je suis
entièrement à l'écouté de ce qu'il va me
répondre
ce ne sont plus mes notes qui guident
l'interview
c'est ce que j'ai ressenti
finalement
c'est un nouvel équilibre que j'ai
trouvé qui fait que ce métier que
j'exécute et avec méthode je les exécute
aujourd'hui avec plaisir et évidence
et c'est ça ce que je voudrais vous
proposer aujourd'hui
et si vous pouviez essayer de
transformer votre corps en radio
pour stabiliser votre voix
pour chercher une nouvelle voie
et puis surtout pour donner du corps à
de l'information pas pour zapper un
média en plus
mais vraiment pour lui donner une vraie
voix à écouter parce que
c'est quand même l'essentiel
informations non
[Musique]